Fox News Alert for the first time in
American history there's never been news
like this and it is historic political
history as it happens it has never
happened before
Donald Trump the unprecedented president
is facing criminal charges
the justice system will be defeated
discredited and totally disgraced
he'd already trailed his indictment on
stage he took to a social media platform
on confirmation of his arrest calling it
political prosecution and election
interference at the highest level in
history
political opposition and resistance his
son echoed the sentiment
kind of stuff that would make Mao Stalin
Paul pot and other sociopaths blush and
it's happening right here in America the
Trump private plane remained on the
tarmac in Florida as prosecutors
negotiated his surrender and transport
to a New York Court
arrested after a hush money payment to
this woman Stormy Daniels a porn star
with whom he had an affair although he
denies it she was paid a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars
days before the 2016 election
prosecutors have been looking at whether
that payment was falsified when it was
put through the Trump books and whether
campaign Finance law was broken
the fixer who handed over the cash a
friend turned four is in no doubt you
have emails you have text messages
recordings
they have all they have all the
information
Matt American
Donald Trump had called for protests at
his indictment but demonstrators have
barely made it into double figure
there will be tight security if and when
he appears here
now this courthouse in lower Manhattan
the trade entrance counts them in for
the common criminal treatment
the addition of Donald Trump will mean
he's fingerprinted here and photographed
a marked short of a former president in
the frame for a felony
it is quite the come down for a man
plotting a comeback to the White House
and this indictment might just be the
least of Donald Trump's legal worries
he's facing investigations too into his
part in the January the sixth
Insurrection into the mishandling of
classified documents and into alleged
attempts to overturn the election result
in the state of Georgia
close by the New York Court iced tea the
rapper and actor has been filming the TV
series Law and Order it's a fictional
series about crime and its consequences
on both counts it's overshadowed by the
reality show coming soon down the street
James Matthews Sky News in Washington